all of a sudden i saw you started
tweeting about bitcoin and stuff and we
got introduced yeah
uh where what's so fascinating about
that so i think that the intro to crypto
was through
my fascination with the nft space and
how i saw
people all across the world were being
awarded this opportunity to
advance not only their professional
degree
their professional careers but um just
economics like
i could invest in an artist in uganda
i can invest in artists in taiwan who
wouldn't have that visibility without
this platform without
um the connectivity and
and the uh what everything that
everything that you're allowed to
utilize through an nft and the stories
that you can tell
and um through that research i i
you know bitcoin and all these they've
always been buzz words and i didn't
really know a lot about it
and um when i tweeted something about
nft and one of my buddies reached out to
me john
marbach and he's like if uh it was like
it was like
it was like morpheus reaching out to nia
he's like he's like if you want to learn
more
like meet me at my apartment at 8
o'clock i was like oh
[ __ ] like i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm in like
i'm getting violent so
he invites me to his apartment
it was hilarious like i get there um and
john's like one of the smart like one of
the smarter people i know went to
college together
um has a place in new york get to his
apartment and he just starts
unloading about how like what his
involvement in the space is and
um the different opportunities that are
there and i'm coming at him hard with
these he's just like the opposition like
well what about this what about that and
he's just like
if you read this if you read that he had
a he had an uh answer for every question
i had
and i did my own research shout out john
yeah john was bro that's the thing i
like about the crypto community though
it's like
people want to educate you on and like
not with misinformation but just like
they want you to understand where
they're coming from and they
not only understand but offer any advice
and
i can't say that for other investment
vehicles financial institutions that
i've participated in the past that
people are so willing to give
information the other ones don't want
you to exactly make money
exactly that's how they make money so
it's like uh
and just from an economic standpoint
like someone who studied economics it
just made sense
there's a fixed supply the demand is
going to go up so the price
has to follow and you know we're in a
volatile time right now
there's probably going to be more but
like the fundamentals of why i invested
haven't changed and what i'm using it as
hasn't changed
and uh as long as those things contin
continue to stay
finite then i'm going to continue to put
money into it so i think it's smart you
got laser eyes on twitter now i got to
raise your eyes
all right when you did that what did
bachelor nation say about laser eyes
they were like yo
oh my gosh it's funny because like that
was like
like there's no d there is literally
nothing that is similar from like
driving a porsche looking fly going to
be
20 girls that are competing for you and
then putting laser eyes
and being like by the dip like those two
worlds are completely different
i'm like and mind you at this time like
the the the mat that people
came to know on the show like clean
shaven like i have i've i haven't shaved
since the show looks like nipsy hustle a
little bit i
appreciate that right that's pretty good
yeah no i
uh i get that a decent amount really
yeah i get that i feel like i'm smart i
just need
i need the cornrows but um but so like
like the pictures that are coming like
they're not hearing from me because i'm
not on the show anymore but like there's
like matt
spot it's like a yeti it's like there's
like dude has a beer and he's like
leaving walmart it's like who is this
guy and then um
and then so then when you leave i'm
gonna take a picture and be like i
spotted man exactly
prickle miami who's some girl i'm gonna
make sure rachel's face isn't in it
oh god here we go the media storm around
that
but um so they're seeing that and then
like the next thing i post is like
like a picture of me in a tuxedo with
laser eyes so like all right this guy's
literally lost his mind like what
is he is he possessed by a demon like
what does this eat
and so but it's cool because it starts a
conversation it's like you know like
to my laser focus to the moon oh what's
that so it just it sparks conversation
that i want to have around something
that i'm interested in
and i'm inviting pushback on so that i
can
um further validify or solidify uh
why i feel have these strong convictions
about
um this investment and uh just the
community in general
so the most interesting thing to me is
as you
kind of uh evolve your interests you
learn more about crypto you learn more
about hydroponics whatever
the audience that you have is literally
180 degree difference than mine right
mine is like if you look i'm like
youtube is like 95 male right
at one time saw that she was like oh we
gotta get some more females like listen
it's just
like the type of the content really
attracts a certain type of person
right uh but you have like 90 95
women right because of the show and all
this stuff and so
do you feel like uh there's an
opportunity to kind of expose
a different audience to different ideas
right regardless of what the ideas are
what the exact audience is
it feels almost like your interests are
very different than what they normally
would kind of consume right
i'm assuming most of your audience
doesn't have laser eyes right almost 100
of my audience has laser eyes right
so it's just like such a different uh
kind of you know circle of people
that you're really introducing a lot of
these new ideas to yeah i think that i
think that when
you're in a position of influence that
you have a responsibility and
um i'm i'm not the chair of the fed
i'm not in controlling that's a good
thing
that's a job that no one can win you
know what i mean like i i have very
little say on
on anything outside of my own opinions
and when i find something that i think
is going to be
something that's going to be here for a
while and something that i want to pass
on to the students and the families of
the students that i work with
then i think that it's a responsibility
to at least make people aware
of um tools that are out there that
they could change the trajectory of
their life and
especially with cryptocurrency i think
that we've seen um
historically communities that have been
marginalized and discriminated against
um can't get loans they can't buy houses
they can't buy cars and like
those barriers to entry don't exist the
way they do
with traditional financial institutions
the way they do with crypto and that was
something that was
intriguing to me because if the families
that i work with
and the kids that we work with have
access to these tools now
and something that i only think is going
to gain momentum
public onboarding and institutional
onboarding going forward
then like it would be an honor for me to
be the person that bridges the gap
between them
and then replicate that uh for women who
are following me you know there's no
reason why they shouldn't be
um a part of this conversation as well
it's it's conversations that rachel and
i have on a regular basis you know
she's constantly challenging my um
thoughts and views on um being a bitcoin
maximalist and
all other things crypto so that rachel
no [ __ ] coins all right
and i like it because it helps me come
to a better conclusion of
of what like what my truths are rooted
in and it helps her understand like oh
like that makes sense
because everything you're saying should
make sense like it's not a secret
there's no like
theorem or it's the intellectual almost
like combat or battle of ideas right
where you come in you're like hey i got
this idea she asked you questions you're
almost in some way educating but at the
same time you're getting a gut check on
you know do i actually know what i'm
talking about i really believe this
exactly yeah uh polina thinks that
satoshi's a female
that is a popular take and i
i think that i don't think that she's
wrong on that really i've heard that
before
and i why do you think that i'll tell
you why she thinks it
i think it because of the rationale that
that went into the protocol and i don't
think it's something that
would have been i think that
i think that men are more greedy and i
think that there would have been some
sort of way to maybe
um hoard the potential i don't know i
just think that it's too fluid of a
system for it to be created by one of us
so planet thinks it could be a female
because
uh men are too egotistical right like
somebody ought to be like yo i made that
[ __ ] that's me
yeah i like that that's so true
but but she's like no actually it takes
a special type of person right which
uh from probability standpoint is more
likely a woman than a man
i don't know who it is i don't want to
know but i think it's interesting
to think through like everyone does
assume
the other thing that i learned recently
is there's only one time ever satoshi
uh revealed gender he was signing up for
something i use him because
uh when he signed up i forget what it
was it asked for
birthday and it asked for gender and
selected male
now could have been thrown into the
gospel right so you don't know right but
like that's the only time
ever that there was gender involved in a
way that
uh satoshi you know kind of um said
anything about their what was the
birthday
uh i forget exact birthday but i put
them in there like i think mid to late
40s
2010 so like mid to late 50s today
interesting all right so i got
it could be could be who knows yeah i
don't think i want to know no no i
definitely don't want to know yeah
there's an element of um if you don't
know nobody can say
uh oh that's far right or far left or
that's a man that's a woman that's a
white person a black person a green
person that's a
american uh you know somebody from
another country uh oh that's a christian
that's a muslim
right that's right it's just nothing so
entire conversation
like knowing that it the protocol yeah i
i think that it's just it's not
bad if people knew all it does is it
just removes
one other thing that people can say
right there's plenty of people who are
like oh i don't like vitalik
right i don't think vitalik's done
anything that's like
worth attacking or being mad at him or
not liking him or anything like that but
it's just like
because they know who vitalik is he
tweets something
everyone freaks out right half the
people are like yes he's you know
he's the king right right people are
like he's an idiot right right right
like
whatever so like that just adds another
level of complexity so it's not so much
like you solve a problem
as much as or that it necessarily
matters as much as just
it's one less thing for people to attack
and so if everyone's yelling screaming
about
bitcoin and oh by the way the creator of
the protocol does something
it just is another kind of attack vector
right